تنضم إلي الآن من الرملة والضفة الغربية
هبة تي، وهي المديرة القطرية للرعاية في
الضفة الغربية وقطاع غزة، شكرًا
جزيلاً لكونك معنا،
شكرًا لك على استضافتي
في مستشفيات غزة عند نقطة الانهيار مع
القصف الإسرائيلي المستمر
وبالطبع نقص الوقود وهذا
يؤثر أيضًا على
عمليات تسليم المساعدات الإنسانية حيث كنا ننشر
آخر الأخبار عن إمدادات المساعدات إلى
المنطقة لأنه على ما يبدو لا
يدخل شيء ولكن أه لا تزال هناك بعض
الإمدادات
المتاحة لذلك اسمحوا لي أن أبدأ  من
الإمدادات الموجودة داخل غزة
للأسف حتى لو كان لدينا الإمدادات القليلة جدًا
لممارسات النظافة أه للإمدادات الطبية فنحن
غير قادرين على نقلها حتى داخل
الشمال بسبب نقص الوقود
كما ذكرت للتو الشاحنات  من
وكالات الأمم المتحدة غير قادرة أيضًا على
تسليم العدد القليل جدًا من
المساعدات الإنسانية التي تدخل إجمالي
ما تلقيناه منذ 21
أكتوبر، وهو ما يعادل تقريبًا
متطلبات يومين من
الإمدادات المتاحة تقليديًا، وهذا
أصبح بالفعل أمرًا بالغ الأهمية  لقد
رأينا أيضًا المخابز التي
تغلق أبوابها قاسية ورهيبة، مما يجعل من
الصعب جدًا على الناس الوصول إلى
الأطعمة الأساسية وللأسف تم الإبلاغ عن نفس الشيء
من أولئك الذين يغادرون
الشمال إلى الجنوب
وهم الآن يقومون بالرحلة  سيرا على الأقدام
لأنه لا يوجد وقود
لنقلهم من الشمال إلى
الجنوب للأسف الوضع صعب جدا جدا
وصلنا للأسف إلى
اللحظة التي لدينا فيها آخر قطرة
وقود تنتهي وتنتهي وهذه
لحظة مخيفة جدا بالنسبة لنا  نحن
كمنظمات إنسانية وطبعا
أصل هذا هو أن أه إسرائيل
تقول أنها لن تسمح بدخول الوقود بسبب
المخاوف من أن حماس ستأخذه
وأعني أنه حدث في بعض الأحيان
أليس كذلك تحدث معنا  حول تأثير
ذلك لأنه من المفترض، كما
سمعنا من رئيس الوزراء بنيامين
نتنياهو، أنه سيواصل هذه
المعركة حتى النهاية، وجزء من ذلك
هو عدم السماح لهذا الوقود بالدخول،
لذلك أصبح من
الصعب جدًا علينا الإجابة على هذا السؤال  الآن في عام 2023 في
الشمال، اسمحوا لي أن أبدأ في الشمال، حيث
الوضع صعب للغاية
ومخيف،
فلا طعام ولا ماء، لم يتبق شيء
في الأسواق، ولم يتبق شيء
للمدنيين للوصول إليه، وأولئك الذين كانوا
بالفعل في الجنوب كانوا
يتقاتلون من أجله  أصبحت الموارد في ذلك
شحيحة للغاية الآن لدينا عشرات
الآلاف ينتقلون من الشمال نحو
الجنوب والتي كانت تعاني بالفعل من
نقص الخدمات من حيث المياه الصالحة للشرب
ومياه الشرب وأغراض النظافة والمياه هاه الطعام
آه الوصول إلى الخدمات الطبية
والمستشفيات نرى المستشفيات واحدة تلو الأخرى
والآخر يعلن أن
المياه تنفد لديهم والكهرباء
غير قادرين على تقديم الخدمات لأولئك الذين
هم في حاجة ماسة إلى هؤلاء الذين
ليسوا جرحى فحسب، بل في
وحدة العناية المركزة الحرجة وهم بحاجة ماسة
للمساعدة الطبية للأطفال والحاضنات هذا  هذا هو
الوضع للأسف،
أصبح الأمر أكثر صعوبة مع إعلان
أونرا ووكالات الأمم المتحدة أن
الأمل الأخير للناس في الوصول إلى الغذاء
أصبح مستحيلاً مع
عدم القدرة على نقل أه
المساعدة الإنسانية للأشخاص
المكتظين في الملاجئ في
الجنوب